honestly the women being almost 50% in
the school of computer science is really
important to me and almost no other
school can can say that some of the
other schools I visited when I was
accepted into an honors college computer
science program I was the only girl in
the room and I don't know if that was
all of the people in the program but
that really made an impact on my
decision of whether or not it was gonna
go to that school when I came to CMU not
only did they have the numbers to show
that they had a lot of women in their
computer science department but they
also were very welcoming to women and
were showing that they wanted to attract
women when I came to visit CMU after I
had been accepted I met Tom Cortina and
he gave a presentation on the school
computer science for the people who were
admitted and he was very charismatic and
he just seemed so passionate about what
he was doing and that was another thing
that was really important to me
sometimes schools are especially that
have these kind of reputations are kind
of just that all about the reputation
but CMU isn't like that at all the
reason that CMU has the reputation is
because the faculty are so passionate
about everything they're doing and they
want their students to learn as much as
they can while they're here